boy
yes
and
willem
yes
the
no
and
we want had
color
we also hold
off
[Music]
I think I
we hear
ok
for
make
underwear
bottom
and
you have to
[  Music]
[Music]
we deliver
must
be heard well here today
yes
how people were used to
now
[Music]
oh no
happy
yes
how
ok
points
[Music]
mulberry right here
[Music]  ]
wifi
[Music]
yes
and
[Music]
yes
on
[Applause]
oh
and
so it's me
[Music]
home
oh
no hear
yes
do
other
owner
ready
and
yes
I will
maybe
we are
in the
bull's
eye on this by hecke koreman
the faster you searched
vga
a
good huh
home
out
only
today it will go
yes
[Music]
this
anyway
[Music]
factor
11 answers
I  mean
bob
no come
[Music]
want
around
[Music]
oh
and
then only his head
yes
a man
[Music]
no
hi
we're going
kilo
we stand before the
departure
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
okay
yes
[Music]
he
ha
ten have
[Music]
then
excite her
this is just a pint of soul again a
school that very mean to say
before the race
there are coming the
way
and not so develop
[music]
hi hi hi hi hi best case
to follow you
no
and
good morning
[Music]
also better
bridge
it's beautiful
well
[Music]
no
yes
[Music]
hey
yes
[Music]
and
that's not much sooner
[Music]
of the
nine of them
think
winning luck
flee white
what
it would be okay
look
[Music]
now
how
lions
[Music]
yes
oh
[Music]
and
[Applause]
well
and
we trust
yes
from
a
a can
okay
not
yes
in
home
kim training
what
a
but
come
learn
on
[Music]
o  h
step
no
and
do it
I'm with you
here
yes good morning
the
have to last
hey
[Music]
top down
no go
hello
no
yes we can
if we wanted
to do nothing
about you
you know what a very long  no
other than ever for me logical and comfort
stay enthusiastic subject
equal not only know my that angry
early so still home we take care of the
world my mother takes care because i
feel dead blue daily damage
so to the michel our motor week is
the chance  for the crown
they must now not
for one the takers renounce and her and
I
concrete that at all costs see
nothing become in the brands what it means
all report about in this holy
struggle
this jihad against the simple wish of a
follow to hear  are fought with a
relief to keep you
from standing here
the vices that opinion was not so
important after all
use for an extreme distribution
you who in the b  raven to listen slave to
follow
lesser people that my days later
was picked up to good Flemish regular school
and myself
[Applause]
full-blooded
to prove that the flame knows
our voice a
little more support stupid someone god loves
as long as you stand not on the world to the
gate
i think i think
it's
be a green and
don't analyze it
[Music]
monique
can handle more
boom
[Music]
no all
again
rounds rounds
rules who want our country sleeveless
today
[Applause]
and
and and
4 hours
hope you
exist without
yes yes
online
[Applause]
whoever they don't
[Music]
[Applause]
symbolically place
us in front of a bullbar
here sometimes more people young people
below
who 400
[Applause]
[Music]
maria geb
hoppa shameful dear man in
individuals speak today
could follow
996 to walk
a nice
precise no one will ever built the source
of grace
[applause] not
now
in
the
netherlands
and
us realize
is or not
in 1994
taxes all over well
[Applause]
sir and
madam heal a european country exactly
[Music]
j
in
and then but don't be afoul of
godsamme
those four all
who don't know how
love
starts with a fine see who wants nice
man
no
i am  here
with a drink
and
ohyes
we had
[Applause]
I
with me
[Applause]
live
hey
[Music]
then that
because the infoteur burps
my head
you
[Music]
but once
why run
no
on
yes
stand under
[Applause]
and
no
[Applause]
hey
I
heard you guys
I'll plan a
[Music]
for a
good cause
okay
in
and you have
no
and people
yes
insulin
women
you
around
I see
life
a very
now
no
[Applause]
in
no
normal
world and a great
an interest in the lake man
our association
but mining
come boy have to do
and finally on social media
foundation
i fall on bibian
for that more
and so conviction
wan  down
here
who visited
and if you were it
now even more
log in
and
then do
one away
to someone
humor
and
and I
end
we are
no
good morning
do not mind your opinion
edit
hey
the form and the
and more not
and
oh
new
one  farmer
do
here
young lad
how
me
no
generally
long come
herman
no
then
and
an evening
hammamet
no
[Music]
and for now
keep our
[Music]
and
food
no
it
and
stay
yes
nice
I
and
is
more
looking at
it
and
the idea
no
hey
in a
no
hi
my
well
yes
completely and
these
maybe your friends
yes
the good
my
doing
I'm
from the close
[Music]
here stood
what me
very russian
skirts
[Music]
hey
yes
and
do
[Music]
no
ah
yes
what
never
nothing because you act
oh
weird
I want to come
I'm
a good
it's a great idea
[Music]
Zeeland
another
[Music]
no no
and
what to do
slopes
ok  é
no hear here
are things why
I want another dimension
a
likes and
still good
okay
he was tired
I add
but
well if
yes
his mother's hey a
validate
here
yes
river nearby
no
hotel
mother
[Applause]
[Applause] [Applause]  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know I don't hear
ours
either
[Applause]
oh
okay
[Applause] go
[Applause]
no
it is
[Applause]
it
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[  Applause]
[Applause]
yes yes
and
[Applause]
I
and
live
ohanyway
[Applause]
the
birds
[Applause]
okay
was
[Applause]
we love
no
[Music]
that
and
because
just a
little garden and
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Applause]
haha
use] hear
[Applause]
yes
m
and
[Applause] are
waiting
[Applause]
to record
and
[Applause]
are
met
do
[Applause]
hey
to
[Applause]
[Music  ]
and
[Music]
but
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
oh
especially youtube afterwards
very occasionally
under all these
he opened the door then
get him
off the tour
okay
reward
[Applause]
[Music] be
good
[Music]
[Applause]
and then women
hey
yes
no
and
come on
[Music]
well
just another
joke
[Applause]
on
yes ok
[Music]
you
how long had
yes
oh
[Applause]
yes
hey
[Music]
miss all said
but
[Applause]
in it
and
[Music]
[Applause]
boy come
okay
yes you the message
the packaging
itself
bad news
music
what get
I am
no
that I am me
ohyes
ok
the
picture
she comes
yes
choir and also do not
welcome
because
was
very good work
l'ampolla
from him
i have  k
[Music]
also
me
and
he
a
home button
no no
back for showing
so now you see the red cross become
is
generally
okay
in
where I lived and drove
contempt
and
in indoor companies
us on
[Music]
to
[  Music]
[Music]